inside out is Pixar's latest film and
it's directed by Pete docter who made up
as well as Monsters Inc two films like
clearly enjoyed and it tells the tale of
a young girl named Riley who's in a very
hard spot in her life she's moved from
Minnesota to San Francisco she has no
friends it's a new school and she's
starting to go through that period in
which she questions herself she gets
snippy with her parents and while all of
these emotions are affecting her we go
inside of her brain and see these
emotions personified as actual
characters we get to see how joy and
sadness and anger and disgust and fear
all interact as actual characters inside
her brain controlling Riley and that's
all I'm going to say I don't really want
to actually let you know the plot of
this movie what actually happens the
things that take place because I think
this is Pixar's best film since Toy
Story 3 this movie reminded me of the
old days of Pixar clever original fresh
unique ideas that are actually very
mature surprisingly mature and
surprisingly making me cry a lot in all
seriousness though this film actually
goes very deep
it really gets underneath the psyche of
what it's like to be a kid in that
strange period where you're starting to
question things and you're starting to
figure out that youth is just youth and
that could float away some day and those
weird and awkward phases you go through
in that strange period of adolescence
leading into puberty and all of the
hardships that come with that and I
expected it to go in those directions
you know cuz the main characters are
emotions so I figured okay it's gonna be
emotional I may cry it might be intense
it could be a little like boy that's a
lot for a kid's movie but I had no idea
how mature this film was going to be I
was so pleased to see a kid's film a
family film that doesn't pander to
children there's no useless pooping
farting burping jokes to make kids laugh
and to be like yeah kids aren't gonna
really like this movie unless we do
something stupid every two minutes it's
nothing like that this is a film that
actually respects kids minds and as the
scroll experiences things throughout
this movie it gets really emotionally
complex and the way the filmmakers chose
to express these emotions
and these thoughts and things within her
memory it's so clever that I don't even
want to spoil it for you I don't want to
talk about it at all I want you to just
see it and be like that's awesome I'm so
glad Chris didn't tell me that because
now I can just watch this movie and
experience it without knowing too much
because it really benefits from it not
knowing because I barely watched a
single trailer for this movie and I'm so
glad I didn't because I didn't really
know what this movie was even about and
it made the film so much better than if
I would have watched the trailers I can
also tell it's a kind of movie worth I
was like six or seven years old right
now I would be really entertained by
inside out I would think it's a lot of
fun but then as I grow up and get older
I would start to recognize the more
deeper elements of the film it would
grow on me in a different way it
wouldn't just be a fun experience it
would actually have a deep impact on me
and that's why inside out is so special
it's a movie that adults can enjoy as
well as kids but a lot of people say
that oh adults and kids can have fun
please quote me in the trailer and on
the blu-ray cover but I really mean this
movie is actually in some ways more
aimed at adults than kids kids can find
a lot of enjoyment in this movie but it
also reminded me in a way of Toy Story
like when I first saw Toy Story I was
like oh Buzz Light beer that's funny I
don't know what that means but then when
I was like 15 I was like a ho Buzz Light
beer I get it now it's a movie that kids
as they grow older will continue to find
things to appreciate and it's not at all
a movie just for kids if you're 45 if
you're 88 you'll probably really enjoy
this film I was shocked how good it was
now this is a Pixar movie so you know
technically it's going to be gorgeous
the animation is beautiful lush and
breathtaking the 3d also of course looks
great for an animated film the depth of
field is amazing and as it stands out
everything looks really good and of
course those are the things you expect
going to a Pixar movie you expect state
of the art technology and where I used
to expect back in the Finding Nemo and
up days with some truly heartfelt
emotion that really got you right here
in the fields and we haven't had that
for a while and inside out has reminded
me what Pixar used to be and can still
be and is I really hope they continue to
make movies like this because inside out
is one of the best family films I've
seen so far this year
two issues I would say the first 10 to
15 minutes were a little slow after the
main plot which I still don't want to
divulge because I think it's so
interesting and so different and so much
fun as soon as that main plot kicks in
the movie was non-stop fun and yeah I
cried twice I'm gonna give inside out an
A I strongly recommend checking this
movie out it's by far Pixar's best movie
in years and don't get up right when the
credits start there's some cool stuff
throughout there you can enjoy as well
guys thank you so much as always for
watching if you've already seen inside
out I'd like to know what you thought of
it and if you're gonna see it let me
know start a discussion about the movie
what do you think of Pixar movies in
general what's your favorite one let me
know below guys and thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes